I'd say New York is the greatest city in
the world who wouldn't want to be mayor
you're a super smart guy Nate so we hope
you don't take this the wrong way but
what exactly do you do we mean your job
never really made sense to us sure you
had connections and you worked really
hard to become the editor-in-chief of
The Spectator but how did you go from
running a newspaper to wanting to run
for mayor we're not exactly sure but
we're going to find out Gossip Girl is a
great show but more often than not it
scenes just don't add up
despite the show wrapping up in 2012
many of its dramatic storylines have
left fans utterly confused keep watching
to find out why Dan and Rufus Humphrey
are the biggest hypocrites in Manhattan
angry girl
well the real Gossip Girl please stand
up everyone was shocked but it was
revealed that Dan Humphrey was Gossip
Girl because well he was the last person
we would have pegged as the know-it-all
blogger but honestly the more we think
about it the less it makes sense
turns out lonely boy has a very creepy
edge to him and it didn't take much time
for viewers to realize that Dan doesn't
have one shred of integrity not only did
he make fun of himself but he also
through his sister and girlfriend under
the bus but for some strange reason
everyone chooses to forgive Dan once
they get over their initial shock what's
worse is that Serena goes on to marry
the person who turned her life into a
waking nightmare Dan pretended to be
someone who could be trusted only to use
his position in the most rotten way
possible if this scenario has happened
in real life Dan would finally know what
being a lonely boy was all about Chuck's
second first time
all right enough about Dan for now
instead let's focus on one of the most
puzzling characters the Gossip Girl
franchise has to offer
the conflicted rich boy Chuck Bass
even Europeans as many of you know Chuck
is only interested in three things money
women and Blair throughout the series
Chuck meets a lot of different women and
boasts about as many encounters and
while there's nothing wrong with the way
Chuck chooses to live his life viewers
caught him talking about his first time
on two separate occasions and what Chuck
confessed just didn't add up
at first Chuck revealed that his first
ever partner was Georgina sparks but
shortly after her Chuck said that his
first time was spent with an Italian
woman so which one is it Chuck we
wouldn't put it past you to lie but
what's the point of lying about your
first time this seems more like a
continuity error than anything else
lily and William live happily ever after
for the first two seasons of Gossip Girl
Serena's father remains a perfect
mystery literally all we know about him
is that his last name is van der Woodsen
but when we're finally introduced to
Serena's dad in season 3 we immediately
wish he'd remained a secret there were
dozens of inconsistencies surrounding
william van der Woodsen like that time
Serena tells Blair that her father
attended Columbia only to tell Dan that
he went to Harvard but when it comes to
William there are only two things we
know for sure he's a doctor and he's one
of the biggest liars of all time what's
even more frustrating however is that
Lily and William end up together at the
end of the series we mean common William
literally convinced Lily that he had
cancer going as far as to give her
medicine that mimicked real-life
symptoms just to get close to her again
that's just evil and not to mention
illegal
William purposely poisons his ex-wife
for personal gain and she forgave him
for crying out loud that just doesn't
make any sense another thing worth
mentioning is that William is first
introduced as Keith in the valley girl
episode and then for some strange reason
the name Keith gets swapped out for
William Chuck's mom and dad now let's
backtrack to chuck who is once again
caught in the middle of a very peculiar
sentence Chuck Bass is an only child and
for most of his life he thought his
mother had passed away giving birth to
him Chuck desperately tried to uncover
the truth about his mom but the search
was far too messy unfortunately he never
did find out the truth about his
long-lost mother but wait something just
doesn't add up remember in the pilot
episode when Chuck was chatting with
Nate well then maybe I should swipe some
of my dad's viagra
my mom's packed well he said something
about stealing medication from his
mother but how is it possible if Chuck
never had a mom in the first place and
why would he lie to his longtime best
friend Nate for no particular reason
hmm this has got to be a continuity
error but while we're on the subject of
Chuck's parents we might as well discuss
his father of Bart and how he
unrealistically faked his own demise we
get it Bart you're rich and powerful but
if you're going to pick your own demise
don't come back to Manhattan live out
the rest of your days in the Bahamas it
just doesn't make any sense that chucks
dad made a comeback especially since
there was a body in its coffin valley
girls this one may not be that big of a
deal but it's a continuity error
nonetheless and we all know that eye
colors don't really change with age and
it's quite obvious that Lily van der
Woodsen has hazel eyes but in the
flashback episode titled valley girls
the younger version of Lily played by
Brittany snow obviously has bright blue
eyes it's not a big deal but producers
could have given Brittany some hazel eye
contacts to make her look the part but
that's not the only inconsistency from
the valley Girls episode eagle-eyed fans
also pointed out that the younger
version of Lily is showcased driving a
car but it's later revealed that Lily
was born in 1969 and since the flashback
episode took place in 1983 that would
make really 14 years old at the time
which is way too young to be driving
Lily could have been joyriding but
that's rather unlikely before we
continue with our video we want to
remind you to subscribe to the bangs if
you love watching videos about your
favorite TV shows and movies hit that
big red subscribe button and to let the
good times roll we post tons of contents
about throwback shows like Gossip Girl
so click that Bell to be the first to
find out when we upload something new if
you're watching on your phone or tablet
go into your YouTube settings and switch
on notifications now let's get back to
the last five Gossip Girl plot holes
next job we spoke about Nate Archibald
job title earlier on but we're still
having some trouble processing the facts
Paris out Nate is a super smart guy even
Dan was impressed by how high his IQ was
but if there's
one thing that just doesn't make sense
it's how Nate became the editor of The
Spectator after Diana was forced to
resign rather to you mr. new
editor-in-chief it was later revealed
that Nate only got a job at The
Spectator because his grandfather
William Vanderbilt was an investor for
the paper
so we've nae becomes a writer for the
paper because of his connections why
would he become the editor-in-chief
connections are great now but how did
Nate know how to do the job without
having any prior experience but what was
even more concerning was howl Nate
revealed that he would be running for
mayor of New York during the series
finale how did Nate go from running a
newspaper to wanting to run an entire
district it just doesn't add up the gang
goes to college
another thing fans picked up on is how
important it was for the gang to get
into college in the earlier seasons and
how unimportant it became once that
storyline was over and done with when a
Blair's biggest aspirations in life was
to make it into Yale this is mentioned
over and over again in season one and
two
and although Blair would eventually end
up at NYU college wasn't something the
show focused on after season three as a
series goes on the main cast is hardly
ever showcased at school it's almost as
if Blair dan Serena and the rest of the
crew have all dropped out of college to
pursue full-time jobs we don't see them
in class or hear them talk about class
while this isn't exactly a plot hole
it's a little strange that's something
that was so important in the first few
seasons was virtually non-existent by
the end of the series Chuck buys a club
everyone knows that it's illegal for
minors to drink and in the USA the legal
drinking age is 21 years old and when we
first meet the Upper East Siders in
season one they're about sixteen years
old
however they have no problem ordering
drinks from prestigious bars sure
they're rich so they can basically do
what they want but if you really think
about it this is a major pothole Serena
Blair Nate and Chuck acts like they're
young adults when in reality they're
just teenagers to make matters worse
Chuck Bass literally buys a hotel with a
club in it
despite being super underage why subtle
for some club in a hotel when you can
just buy the hotel
these Upper East Siders must have the
best fake IDs in the world what happened
to Scott
we wouldn't exactly call this next one a
plot hole but it's bugged us from the
very beginning after all these years
were still wondering what happened to
Scott Rosson his existence was one of
the biggest surprises of season two
Scott is the love child of Lily van der
Woodsen and Rufus Humphrey Rufus and Dan
find out the truth through CT and Chuck
respectively and Rufus is outraged that
Lily chose to keep their son a secret
from him in season three Scott finally
makes an appearance and it adds plenty
of drama to the show many of us thought
that Scott would become a main character
because well why else would the writers
bring him into the storyline but boy
were we wrong Scott attended lily and
Rufus his wedding and then poof he was
gone never to be heard of again so what
was the point of introducing him in the
first place like father like son Rufus
and Dan Humphrey pride themselves on
being nice guys but there's nothing nice
about them in fact we'd go as far as to
call them the biggest hypocrites in
Manhattan at least people like Chuck
don't pretend to be something they're
not but now that we know who Gossip Girl
is we can finally look at Dan with a
fresh pair of eyes it's hard to believe
that Dan used to give Serena advice on
how to become a better person when he
was the one who was using the Upper East
Sider secrets to get ahead in life and
Rufus is no better on multiple occasions
Rufus judged other parents for not
putting their children first only to
take off with his band leaving his two
teenagers to fend for themselves and
let's not forget that time Rufus moved
in with Lily choosing to let Dan and
Jenny
live on their own now that isn't
something a responsible parent would do
and that's a wrap on the top ten pop
holes in Gossip Girl that still needs to
be explained who is your favorite
character from the show which couple did
you ship the most sound off in the
comments thanks for watching don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up we'll see you next time